jour j moins deux pour l'ouverture du
procès barbie 800 journalistes sont
attendus pour ce procès historique qui
est aussi un procès pour l'histoire le
procès en effet sera retransmis par les
télévisions
mais il sera aussi enregistré pour
l'histoire par la télévision
paul lefèvre premier procès jamais
filmés en france dans son intégralité et
pour l'histoire
cinq caméras de fr3 en permanence une
régie complète un film réalisé sous la
surveillance d'un magistrat celui ci
doit fait respecter les équilibres des
prises de vue un travail considérable
le président des assises pour à chaque
instant
arrêtez l'enregistrement si un témoin
par exemple refuse d'être filmé chaque
jour les cassettes seront mis sous
scellés par le président des assises qui
les vérifiera et qui les confiera aux
archives de france
ce film destiné à l'histoire ne pourra
être utilisé que dans 20 ans aucune
répétition n'étant possible
il s'agira d'un véritable direct tout
est prêt pour cette expérience dont on
saura vite si elle est bénéfique pour la
justice le procès peut commencer